here this this is miss survival I saw it
on Steam it had good reviews for it it's
like a single-player Zombie Survival
kind of thing so I'm gonna try it out
and do that thing ooh
who do you get Sam at a shelter
management based shelter shelter command
you can manage the shelter by observing
the house symbol the dwelling will have
the symbol on the front door when you
enter the shelter's command mode you can
choose to change the base shelter and
manage to the survivors in your camp
survivors are only active in 50 meters
around the base mister vent the
appearance of each fog is company by
some events players must be prepared
infectious can come out outdoors only at
night or when there's no Sun that means
they can also hunt while the fog is
covered traveling in fog is quite
dangerous but in the mean time and this
was at the village ability of bandits
worsened as well bow and arrow
high-performance equipment can be used
without noise suitable for hunting or
assassination you have to install the
quiver that contains the arrows already
before you can use it the higher quit
you can switch arrows while using the
bow pressing our longbow can be used to
kill bandits and single shots when use
with hunting arrows fatigue and stamina
press 7 to sleep on the ground good to
know all right so this is mist survival
I think it was miss survival which I
think just means that we got to survive
in the mist so I guess it's kind of like
a forest style survival thing but give
give give to me give ok
we got that I could sleep shelter
command well this is a [ __ ] shelter
manager room by clicking the green space
we don't even have rooms it's just 2
sticks but Bear Grylls would be pissed
off at me small house that says this
isn't a house it's very clearly not
houses just a pile of sticks and leaves
with like some kind of a tarp a carpet
this isn't even like an animal skin this
is literally a carpet that it turned
upside down why did I turn a carpet
upside down why didn't I sleep on the
shag side what if this even mean this is
us yeah whatever oh well I'm a rest
destroy it no I'm gonna break it you
can't destroy base shelter well why the
[ __ ] not sleepy peepee just away dat
baby bed hope northern attacks me while
I'm sleeping ok whatever
come back and destroy that once I find a
better shelter okay well I'll pick up a
lot of sticks and stones and the such as
got that if I know anything from the
forest so I got I got blueberry I don't
know why that was on the ground well
they're blueberry who is who's skipping
through the forest just shoveling a
basket of blueberries into their mouths
missing haphazardly like and ruining it
about all over the ground can I quit my
saw a few months to winter that sounds
pretty good
okay I'm gonna quit my saw here we go
and blueberry okay here we go I must saw
I'm a saw [ __ ] I'm gonna saw Oh
minecraft stop baby I'm gonna punch the
[ __ ] out of this tree oh I'm so angry
give me your wood I saw you see in a
video game once please help I hear the
couch yowsa
couch ouch whoo yeah ouch whoa
hee-hee-hee ouchies oh okay whatever I
guess I can't do that yet so I need to
go find just some basic logs maybe and
then I can do something I'm just gonna
go I'm gonna assume that rocks aren't
exactly uncommon so maybe I don't need
to pick them all up
let's go see what the rest of this world
is about before I start doing that stuff
oh it's a power line I'm gonna lead me
towards civilization of some sort maybe
I can get like a better better home base
something like that
anybody hello got leaf got blue bear hey
there's some hello hello over there I
thought that was a person does this work
Oh
Oh fill the tank
I don't have gas yes I do low-grade fuel
animal oil great for fuel fire nah [ __ ]
can't do it this isn't a biodiesel what
[ __ ] thing hello open shelter command
who set his base yeah I can go get
destroyed the other one wait can I make
this my base no I can go destroy the
other one all right the day of reckoning
is at hand [ __ ] oh you stupid stick
shelter you're gonna get it oh you're
gonna get a face full of punch you
thought you'd get away from living no
not today also I was like I was like 10
feet away from all right anyway that was
weird
all right you're getting rekt all right
destroy ya take ten minutes ten minutes
of beer walloping anger won't take this
yes please can I have this can I have
this can I have this leaf I have this
rope all right we're good well let's get
you a tea it's like I don't know where
you're falling from but I don't like it
but it's like some kind of survival game
kind of reminds me of rust and the way
original dayz lately whoa whoa whoa bear
bear bear where's your bear hey my leg
why why would you why there bear what's
the scariest thing I've ever seen
ah well alright then that's new I don't
know that was gonna be a thing but I got
a knife now and an axe inventory upgrade
Oh a Cola a bandage I probably need that
yes please can fruit I'll take the cola
I know I should take the canned fruit
but I'm not gonna oh boy okay let me let
me eat let me bandage that was
horrifying eat that man the temperatures
going up way fast
the temperatures forty four point five
degrees Celsius that's why 45 degrees
cells how much weight way forty-five
that's a hundred and thirteen degrees 46
because I'm in this building what's the
deal what the hell all right treatment
my leg leg treatment go all right okay
let's put the axe there no let's take
this okay okay I can't I guess I can
never move that ever again this is just
permanent okay all right well mm-hmm
okay
all right that's just the way that is
okay oh I can make stuff but let me go
out at least let me make sure the coast
is clear from no bears I see you bear I
see you over there
all right listen bear I'm gonna go over
here I'm gonna go chop oh the tree the
Christmas tree all right
you okay mr. bear all right if you come
over here I got a knife almost stab you
I got a hole ninja-style you ain't gonna
do nothing to me
stupid bear or hang on let's go whompin
that's not I had on this side
[Music]
oh yeah I'm just turning my back to this
bear that was over there who knows if
it's still there mmm I don't know
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
okay well it was falling realistically
right up in there until the end okay log
log log log log I got log so was it that
bear that was making the rocks all fall
down something like that maybe I don't
know seems like it might have been
something was going off there no no what
but it wasn't fun and nope right at the
end there gets all kind of against
physics okay
so I got some logs I don't have any gas
but now I've got a home base so oh I'm
full up apparently so I can make
firewood I can make regular wood which
is probably good let me do some regular
wood standing out in the open there's a
bear over wait is that for wait whoa
they said something about fog wait a
minute wait a minute they said something
about fog I remember the name of this
game might be mist survival maybe I
could beef up the other defenses here
but maybe I could there's like a hammer
a sleeping bag I don't have any
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] how do I make up mm can I
make a bowl just gonna grab these hope
nothing bad happens okay miss gone
apparently I guess the mist is gone it's
gonna get night here soon and that's
probably not good why does it keep
saying I have so many logs I don't have
that many logs logs
okay now I'm apparently out of logs but
just hasn't updated okay so I'm slightly
wounded I don't know I don't know when
that happened I thought I thought I was
fully unmuted but apparently not I'm
just gonna create keep making these cuz
I don't know when and where I'm supposed
to not do this alright that's good I'm
out of bandages too so I guess I'm just
[ __ ] I'm gonna leave here I'm gonna go
somewhere else I don't know where that
bear would the Bears right there okay
I'm gonna go in the opposite direction
of where the bear was and hopefully not
run into another bear hey here's
something well that looks fun I like to
look at this I don't know who built a
house in the middle of nothing not even
a road leading up to it but I like it
oh there is a road I'm just an idiot
okay so does this one have any gas in it
I bet not
no no gas okay I bet doesn't even work
all right
hello anybody home I got an axe just so
you know whoo knock knock knock knock
can't unlock it I don't have a crowbar
okay wood wood wood duh what is this it
I can't get to the other area I guess
okay I don't have a lockpick and I don't
have a crowbar they got a lot of
firewood though so that's nice for them
but not much else of anything else
I just bash open one of these yeah yeah
why not right right right right
Oh
what broke right just break what adds
break what did I break not what I wanted
to break well what did I break I don't
know whatever
okay that didn't work let's move on it's
gonna be night soon ooh there's another
bear I don't want to get in a fight with
a bear what is that
what are those Oh wind turbines is this
a farm man I know nothing about this
game but there's a barn over there so
I'm assuming that there's gonna be stuff
towards the buildings I mean that's just
my general instinct on anything this
one's got gas but this one's got no oh
but wait maybe I can fill the can no but
maybe if I find a can I can fill I get
this one has gas in it so yeah oh oh the
trunk oh da the trunk okay I'm gonna put
beef kick me again
it could be kept for a long time without
spoil let me put my rocks in here I'm
gonna take the components match is
probably important sticks not as much
but I'm not gonna
just anything in the Aaron's gonna put
the rocks in there I should have checked
the trunks on the other one then but I'm
done can can can oa4 gasps oh okay so
can put this here fill the can now we
got gas all right cool we got two point
eight five liters of gas cool so now I
can go over to the other car that I saw
and I should definitely be checking the
trunks of these bad boys but there was
another car over here so let me just go
over here and check the trunk first and
then I can use this is like my storage
vehicle and always keep stuff in it and
it'll be good to go right oh it's got no
tires oh that's that would be a problem
okay yeah this says okay this this is
more problem than just no gas okay I bet
the other one had tires though because
it had an option to actually drive it
right why what happened was weird okay
whatever Zef tires no tires okay that's
a problem okay well I'm gonna fill the
tank up ah tires need to go get tires
okay problem all right what if I just
here we go okay close I don't think it's
going nowhere okay so that's going
nowhere but but but but what but big but
let me let me fill the can take this
with me but now I think I got an idea of
what I'm gonna do so oh I need to grab
that can so I think I'm gonna use this
as my home base I'm gonna fill the
locker with stuff that things I don't
need like this extra wood I don't need
yet this stick these sticks I can get
that anywhere I'm gonna take the rope
the fuel the matches some food and some
water that's why I'm gonna take with me
I'm gonna go over to that barn I'm gonna
see what's up it's cool like this is a
surprisingly well-made game I mean this
is an early access one so I just saw it
randomly on Steam but I was like hey
what seems like it's got some potential
here oh cool I'll take that hammer that
seems useful I don't know why but it
seems useful does Ainley ooh give me
your [ __ ] give me your
give me your give me R fuel this is cool
does it have a motor I have no idea
don't ask me I don't know I don't know
why the hay is glowing slightly
irradiated Hey
well whatever Oh another car this one's
got tires Oh God Oh get in the car bear
bear bear bear bear bear bear bear but
get in the car Oh God bear bears are now
officially the scariest thing in this
game it's gonna sneak Chabad that bear
is terrifying that bears were goddamn
terrifying that bears [ __ ] terrifying
what is this a blueberry perfect I'm
just gonna gun it to forget the forget
the car for now I'll get it later when I
could actually see what's going on
around me but um it was the Bears car
anything at the top of the water tower
oh this looks this looks safe okay
alright sure oh hey tractor are you
drivable chicken mmm okay alright tire
cool the other tire wait I've got
matches let me see if those can provide
a little light for me all right six
tonight I'm holding a match two handed
it's a very big match okay components
rag that's useful good motor rag I can
make a sleeping bag out of a rag as far
as I know crafting components whatever
that means combat knife just bare I
guess doesn't seem like much is there an
actual like farmhouse can I kill these
chicken okay kill the chicken oh you
better run over buck buck buck buck I
guess I can't catch the chicken so yeah
this is my question okay but if I get
four tires and then I can get like an
engine I can salvage enough stuff out of
this I just wish I could see it is
really dark oh I don't like the way you
just saved like that ominously so what's
why he's glowing okay there's a barn up
there so that's probably something a
little bit better for me to be see coal
oh I'm full already geez okay I'll drink
something drink
okay lug eat uh yeah let me eat this
brightness I'm not gonna cheat what [ __ ]
cheating in my farm cheating I thought I
told you about cheating I warned you
once and I won't warn you twice no ain't
gonna be no cheating here turn up my
brightness oh yeah
I'll remember that the next time I go
camping I'll just pray to God be like
please sir turn up the brightness in the
night no no no no no cheating happening
here you cheating cheater Junior we got
a cheater here or somebody call 1-800
sheeter
what I made myself clear know how I feel
about cheatin and the dirty rotten
cheaters that want to cheat in this
beautiful sky a big moon on this
beautiful night you want me to cheat ooh
that one looks in pretty good shape not
gonna lie I want to he's both looking
pretty good shape I think I might have
found the mother lode and well this is
not in good shape cuz I can't even
interact with it okay maybe not that one
now it's not in good shape this one's in
probably [ __ ] shape it's got nothing all
right whatever but it's by a river it's
a big house big house I like this oh hi
zombie hello oh hey listen it's your
house I see that now the error of my
ways um okay oh it's a train it's a
conga it's a conga line of zombies is it
that time already oh that oh they're
gone okay I'm gonna go over here
it looks like I may be able to build a
fire here
I mean that'd be nice Melman - what what
the [ __ ]
affords a large candidate Act wait oh
they're still there okay let it be known
that they're still there but i see
something across the pond I'm gonna go
swimming boy a bad idea but I'm gonna go
I see you lit so maybe there's some
friendly people over there I want to
give me a good time
hello please help me I'm Oh No
is that a bear my matter stamina please
help me help me help me oh god help me
help me
oh that guy's got a gun um he doesn't
look friendly um what if I sneak up on
him he's probably friendly let's just
get let's just say that I'd like to
assume the best out of people and this
guy's probably friendly alright cuz I'm
gonna go up and almost say hi I'm gonna
go say hi I'm just just gonna say hi I
don't know what happened to my axe but
it's gone let's go say hi no no no I
didn't know there was an execute button
I didn't know that all right fine revive
ow
I'm tired they take my turn my turn okay
we can we can come back from this we're
very bleedy we're very extremely
bleeding it's still only day one life is
not going well
but we've got a hammer we're all good we
can still make this work I'm gonna go
back we're gonna execute him properly
take his [ __ ] and then we're gonna get
gone and everything is gonna be hunky
Dickie and I'm gonna be happy and you're
gonna be happy we're all gonna be happy
I don't trust any noise that's coming
out of this forest I don't like any
noise
I don't wanna Nina please no nothing ow
why am i bleeding why am i bleeding Oh
cuz my leg is wounded severely shouldn't
be sprinting on this wounded
bullet-ridden
leg-oh well I don't know this game very
goodly yeah what's the worst thing gonna
happen was where I could keep running on
this bad boy
apparently not I have no stamina but you
know I could keep running on this bad
boy wait wait seven to sleep on the
ground right in the safety of a bell
here we go just a nice nap oh I'm dead I
was just napping I was gonna be nappy
bye-bye okay start over please no bears
zombies aren't even the main problem I'm
[Laughter]
we're gonna start over forget all of
that we're gonna forget all of it forget
all of that forget it
wow you just go lie down and relax [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
why would I want to do that that sounds
dumb I'm gonna charge into this game
well you think I can't do it oh you
think I can't do it
[Music]
[Applause]
starting over is cheating in what world
it's starting over cheating does that
Jamie you're starting over
alright okay I got this yeah we're good
we're good
I'm not gonna put that in my inventory
or my quick bark cuz I know that's not
gonna work out for me alright we're
gonna go for this we got all the all the
life or love in our heart we got who we
feel it will feel good we feel like who
the world's our oyster we feel like the
whole world's ahead of us there's no
bears there's no zombies there's no
bandits there's no stupid they put that
bear there for a reason I stuck on a
tree stupid bear that's what you get
that's what you get okay so I gotta go
find the gasps can I believe the gas can
that I first found if this is all the
same was over there so I'm gonna loot
the things here my scrap metal here a
hammer I didn't see that before
that's good okay no bears ah now we're
getting into business okay painkillers
toss those back down my gob right now
get fruit and a cold ah sure okay
I'm addicted gasps out of this one
alright that's a lot of gas that's okay
alright so now we're gonna go with
Dhamma forget that base I don't want
anything to do with anything that was
over there I want to go straight for
what I wanted there's a there's a bandit
base over there probably I don't know I
tried to stab that guy but you know
that's probably my fault he was probably
gonna be totally friendly Oh like the
way look at this look at the shimmering
huh look at that
I don't usually comment on graphics too
much but that's a nice detail
let's talk about amber waves of grain if
you don't know about America and how
America is amber waves of grain this is
what we're talking about here just
[ __ ] beauty mmm all right I love
American so do we all so oh say can you
see by the dawn's early light what so
proudly we hail'd did I forget my gas
can add the twilight's last gleaming
whose broad stripes and bright stars
through the perilous barn we're gonna
get some stuff we're gonna go to the
house we're gonna kill a bunch of
zombies wombo combo and we're done okay
I can't pick up the tire that's alright
I probably can't pick up anything
because I'm full of [ __ ]
okay I'm gonna dig the fruit Ashish of
that inside me oh how I just ripped that
open I think I just bit into it and like
ripped it open with my teeth and let's
see if I can carry this tire now I'm
gonna drop this bottle the tire okay
we're good to go
alright let's go in here we're gonna
stab some zombies hey hey [ __ ] holes
hey [ __ ] dicks
hey titty sprinkles hello oh oh oh
you're faster than I thought you'd be
whoa hey okay you didn't tell me that
you could run hey whoa whoa whoa if I
can execute a person maybe I can execute
it Zombo this might be more challenging
than I thought Oh someone's grumpy can
no backdoor okay so I gotta go straight
up in there I see you oh I see you
alright
the benefit is they despawn after a
certain distance which is awfully nice
of them oh this is weird
oh it's creepy here I can use any gun
this is a farm in America so they should
have some guns whoa hello you look sad
okay why are you so sad he's looking
away come on just gonna try try to get
up here get up in get up in there get up
in there
oh okay
use use that don't mind if I do
oh [ __ ] oh man they're all over the
place but uh please don't please oh
there ain't ain't oh they okay okay they
they've lost I've lost my scent oh oh
they found much scent they found my
scent they found my said uh oh god oh
god oh god oh god he's not going away
okay you way I don't like that the fog
we're doing on the roof Lelaina what are
you doing you don't even have a fiddle
what are you doing on the roof oh no oh
no oh that's ominous okay how's my
health doing okay not too bad not
surprisingly not bad oh wow it's gonna
be worse right God just give me a chance
look ah come here
you I'm gonna get you oh oh oh you see
you I don't know how Oh
[Music]
no you go mono you get mono we're one
mono to mono
I'm gonna mono you you wanna me you go
mono mono one two three
we mono each other call it a mono 69 I'm
a mono while you wanna me mano a mano 1
in 1 2 plus 2y don't make it 3 Three's
Company
two's a crowd mono mono who you wanna
mono
hey come here I've got mono for you mono
mono mono yeah you thought you could
[ __ ] me turns out you got mono it back
no mono it's gonna last enough I've got
the mono Y mono to hear mano a mano in
Spanish is bono I'm gonna mono til you
Mon Ami hey how you doing what's going
on a pretty thing thank you thank you
I'm over there you're wrong those mono
mono here mono up right behind you
alright
well glad that's over I'll take your
rags and hope you learned your lesson
glad wood cleared up that and now we can
carry on
oh that's alright you know you win some
you lose some and he lost some but I'm
gonna win some now I'm gonna go over
here and just uh I'm gonna take care of
the rest of the zombo's and house that's
all gonna be is to it
my dying I'm dying aren't I huh I need
let's take some painkillers I guess my
lag my oh my ouchie leg what I can't
take some painkiller there's a big
killer pig [ __ ]
who needs painkiller right all right I
got a hurry and take care of this or
else I'm gonna die
no matter what I do so I just got to go
in here and I've gotta stab some [ __ ]
and hopefully everything will turn out
fine how do you get into this garage
Zera there's a door over here maybe
there's a gun in the garage or something
I don't hear zombies anymore
ah [ __ ] all right hey zombies in here no
really I don't hear anything maybe maybe
they took pity on me
well let's under the kitchen sink yeah
sure what better place for bullets to be
right sugar sugar could I make a sugar
bomb or something I really want a gun
and some medicine I will need some
medicine eventually I am gonna keep
bleeding if I if I don't take care of it
I'm pretty sure I'm just gonna die
you've gone that side gun that gun no
bathroom gun mirror gun no dammit well
[ __ ] I don't have a crowbar with which
to break into any of this I'm probably
not gonna luck out am I probably not
little scraps I just need to get rid of
the [ __ ] see that I don't need sugar
until I know it yeah I'm gonna get rid
of a raw potato
I've got enough matches I'm gonna die
only two bullets yeah maybe one hammer
okay metal scrap seems important because
then I could make stuff out of it right
crafting is probably gonna be pretty big
in this sewing kit can I so up my wounds
looks like a big nope on the gun kid's
room kids room gun maybe no it's like a
big negative on that one all right no
gun in the earth yeah a lot of good
stuff but no gun maybe there's something
in the barn that I could use if I don't
get a med kit soon I'm gonna be very in
trouble or at least some bandages if I
hadn't lost him when I died which was
totally [ __ ] I'm still swinging my
arms okay all right see if there's
anything in here there's another house
over there or a building of some sort
nope let me go over to this building
maybe I can make it my home base and
then go for the bandit place I didn't
see this before because obviously it was
too dark yeah let's make this my base
all right new base sad-ass base perfect
thank you lockar perfect the sugar I'll
put in there these bullets until I know
what bullets I'm gonna need no point the
rags ooh I know I need booze okay some
extra rags the this the tire and I'll
keep the sewing kit on me just in case
okay cool let's go see what's out of
this camp and then I'm gonna go say hi
to the people in the band of base and
maybe go up to that tower there's
probably something good up there
hola and some fruits that's it man I
wish I could open these up these look
like good cars why can't I open them
please tell me I'm not just gonna get
shot straight up as soon as I get close
to this thing I'm hoping I might be able
to sneak in grab some bandages and get
out but probably not gonna be that easy
[Music]
okay um poof whoa okay that guy patrols
over here want to wait behind this
dumpster oh I just need to take one of
them if I can give one of their guns
wouldn't get out oh no no it's okay god
damn it it wouldn't get out of the loot
menu wouldn't get out I'm okay I got my
tongue I got that guy's chocolate so I
really I'm the winner here and stupid
idiot I got the chocolate dumb who
thinks he won no dumb my god I got the
chocolate you think he you think it and
then I'll be like and I'ma be like yes
cuz I got the chocolate I got that
chocolate so really I'm the winner here
I'm the winner I'm a winner
I win things a lot I like to win I win
at a great deal of things and pretty
goddamn good at my winning I just want
to see if there's like a gun on the
ground because it wasn't on his body
but maybe it's one of those things where
it's not geared it's it's that weird
game mechanic where he has a gun very
clearly has gun but he's not guaranteed
to drop the gun like that's the thing
that's the discrepancy I'm gonna soup
you should oh there's a building over
there too maybe there's something in
there I like I want I'm sneaking I get
quieter cuz I'm like a little Jewish
don't wanna spook him okay doesn't look
like anything that was their sewing kit
wait is that my [ __ ] wait is that the
[ __ ] I dropped wait if I go back no
please okay is it is it like that where
if I go back to where I was I might be
able to get my stuff again maybe no you
don't see nothing I don't know
you talkin bout Meester imma steal your
soda why can I steal this ooh I thought
I saw somebody you compare Li can't
steal things when you're crouched didn't
know that a gun I see you got in there I
want that this is probably like the
hardest way you could possibly play this
game trying to assault like this bass
with nothing but a knife and some
blueberries but I'm doing it I'm doing
it I'm gonna do it I'm doing it
oh I am doing currently am do okay so it
seems like it's just these two guys that
guy don't even have a gun
stupid idiot and this guy off to the
right picking him off
yeah that guy so this guy patrols back
and forth II all back he forth he like
but none of them seem to look over this
way so maybe if the front doors unlock
oh that there was another guy there was
another guy I thought there was I don't
know where he was where did he go
where'd he go where'd he go Oh Darius
oh ah into the sunday okay here's how
I'm gonna play this because I killed
that guy off to the left first last time
and that didn't go good for me so I'm
trying to kill the guy off to the right
this time and that'll probably also not
go good for me but I'll feel good about
it you know I'm gonna put a toe and
broccoli this guy grabbed this body okay
let's grab it T I'm grabbing it
grabbing I'm grabbing the body I'm I'm
grabbing TT
tea okay that's good there that's good I
guess
yeah see no gun or that dumb or that big
dumb or that big dumb why no gun his gun
fake it not real it it's fake
okay so I got that guy I don't know why
that guy's patrol is so weird but it's
okay because what I'm gonna do next is
I'm gonna get this guy when he's away oh
there it is a [ __ ] okay I'm not gonna be
able to get that but oh [ __ ] Oh what are
you doing what are you doing can I go
get you should I go get you right no
okay no good good call good call on the
no maybe I should go for the guy in red
huh what do you think guys we think you
think I should huh now you're right
stupid move still the move super move go
for this guy
don't turn around what do nothing
happened some bullets no more broccoli
okay just one more guy that's it oh [ __ ]
my webcam why'd my webcam dead
hello okay whatever I got him here we go
here we go here we go here we go yeah
and so photos blink and beef head beef
okay
well still no gun if I can't even open
this door after all that I'm gonna be so
pissed okay good good good shot gun yes
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah you got
crowbar in there you guys got a crowbar
guys got some lockers ones open oh yeah
this is the good stuff oh this is what
they call some good stuff okay so
inventory rifle I don't have any rifle
bullets I don't think I got rifle now I
just need some bullets okay whoo that
was tough but we made it
wonder if I can bash down this door or
something no
Oh get out get out get open oh oh oh oh
oh oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] there was another all your
friends are dead sorry about that I
don't know where he is you must have
gone back maybe I could maybe I can use
that to my advantage and try to distract
people oh [ __ ] no no no oh okay
where are you going yeah well he's on
alert but I don't know if it's a good
idea to try to sneak up on that guy but
I want to try I'm gonna lose my gun
we're gonna lose my hard-fought gun but
I want to try this oh god damn it the
camera again oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] please zip
tag no please please please
zarbor Dean in the woods there beneath
serpentine serpentine Oh hem serpent
oh oh oh my leg my leg all right so
things didn't go I I gotta I gotta get
the camera I don't know why it's all
like that
Oh No please no I just wanted some duct
tape I know I know you're missing the
face cam do you think I'm dumb I know it
you [ __ ] think I'm done you see what
I'm doing huh you trying to deal with it
ow my leg oh okay
that's gonna be it for now thank you
everybody so much for watching I didn't
do well but I did something so that's
something thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next one bye
[Music]